two weeks of protests by angry eastern
sudan tribes have brought operations at
port sudan to a standstill
the protesters from the media and
hadandawa tribes have blocked roads and
exits to the port forcing it to close
this in protest at what they say is the
region's lack of political power
and poor economic conditions
the government just takes all the tax
from our ports
without leaving us anything sudan is not
held together by war or rule of the gun
we need them to wholeheartedly talk with
us as we have genuine grievances
the protesters are also angry with a
deal the transitional government signed
with sudan's rebel groups in october
last year
in the south sudanese capital juba
widely known as the juba accord the deal
includes a wealth sharing agreement as
well as reparations for those hacked by
the country's long conflict
it also promises that a ton of refugees
displaced by fighting assassin
we are totally against the juba accord
we were not invited and the whole
process was hijacked by foreigners the
government knows who our leaders are too
well let them start talking with them if
they want this blockade lifted
sudan's transitional government has
pledged to work on a political process
to resolve the problems of eastern sudan
but it's adding the protesters who have
blockaded this pot
to lift it immediately the government
has also said the country is on the
verge of running out of essential
medicines fuel and wheat the protesters
however deny they've been holding back
shipments of food and medical supplies
the statement from the government was
only meant to gain sympathy from the
public throughout the protests we
haven't stopped even a single shipment
of food or medical supplies from leaving
the port
the demonstrators agreed last sunday to
allow the resumption of exports of crude
oil from landlocked south sudan through
our terminal on the red seaport there
also forced the closure of a pipeline
that carries imported crude to the
capital cartoon
sudan was already facing shortages
stemming from the economic upheaval
caused by the overthrow of president
umar hasan al-bashir
in 2019
muhammad al-jazeera portugal